one of the last high speed trains to
arrive from China before the rail link
is shut down and the arrivals hall was
packed no health checks here but public
appeals to turn themselves in should
they feel unwell besides this rail link
ferries to are stopping and half the
boundary crossings are being closed with
these measures are seen as really quite
poultry by many in Hong Kong the traffic
between the city and mainland China
makes Hong Kong particularly vulnerable
to the spread of the virus and few think
this is going to do much to halt that
spread everyone here wants a face mask
and they'll queue all day to get one the
city wracked by pro-democracy protests
for the past eight months now faces a
fresh crisis and the fear is
particularly acute here the SARS virus
in 2003 killed hundreds the most deaths
outside of mainland China and many feel
the nightmare is back quite difficult
due to purchase people are people
beginning to panic do you think in Hong
Kong yeah I think so are you
distrust in the authorities built up
during the democracy demonstrations has
morphed into violence over its handling
of the coronavirus this was meant to be
a quarantine facility but the furious
crowd felt it to be too close to other
flats and nearly a year of rioting has
led to firm suspicions about every
government decision the gamble paid off
within hours the neighboring residents
were being told the plans for the
quarantine facility had been halted put
all the carriers to the corner from
there we went to one of the government
quarantine facilities set up in woodland
hidden deep inside a Nature Reserve
no one's allowed out until they've
cleared the 14-day incubation period
according to provider might be night
security and not other people to go from
inside to outside Hong Kongers feel
they're on the front line of this viral
crisis and few here have confidence
their government can contain it Alex
Crawford Sky News Hong Kong